the russians deny they're targeting  civilians but plenty of homes are being  hit in the fight to seize this city  a few meters away from the flames in  this building we find eehor a pensioner  who's struggling to accept his flats  been bombed overnight  both floors above his are burned right  through  are you still are you still staying in  there  with smoking flats all around him his  determined sprinkling of water to bring  down the heat doesn't seem nearly enough  to stop the fire's march  yet the pain of giving up what's his is  too much and it's this refusal to give  in that we've seen repeated over and  over again in this country